[Music]
have you been playing the injustice to
closed beta these past couple of weeks
well you don't shoot the messenger but
you won't be able to do that for much
longer as it's about to come to an end
I'm Matt this is a game spot news update
and make sure to LIKE and subscribe to
stay up to date on all of our coverage
of super hero fighting action
netherrealm studios announced the betas
end date on its forum saying thanks to
all of our players who took part in the
injustice to online beta we received a
great deal of data that will help make
the launch of our online modes the best
they can be now it is time to get busy
implementing the changes that means
unfortunately we will be turning off the
beta on Tuesday februari 21st injustice
two launches for ps4 and xbox one on May
sixteenth some of the recently revealed
characters include Swamp Thing cheetah
and poison ivy and you can expect
another one on februari 23rd will report
back when they are revealed but in the
meantime check out our gamespot universe
channel where you can get all the videos
on superhero movies TV shows and comics
you could possibly want